l'industrie alimentaire fait preuve
d'une grande habilité quand vient le
temps d'attribuer une image santé à un
produit qui est loin de posséder ce type
de vertu le cas des boissons gazeuses
est un exemple probant par exemple cette
rugby mise sur l'ajout de sucre de canne
naturel pour projeter une image
avantageuse du sucre or le sucre de
canne naturel c'est quand même du sucre
même s'il est un peu moins transformés
que le sucre blanc est ce qu'on reproche
aux boissons gazeuses ce sont les trop
grandes quantités de sucre ajouté dans
ce contenant 2 341 millilitres c'est 37
grammes de sucre on retrouve soit
presque 10 cuillérées à thé de sucre
comme dans la plupart des autres
boissons gazeuses et que dire de ce
format qui vous est offert en
restauration bien ça c'est 63 g de sucre
alors ouvrez l'oeil pour éviter les
pièges des belle façon de nommer le
sucre